we've already discussed it here on
visual politic margin Tina is a country
where football is practically a state
religion and we're not a single decade
goes by without at least one major
economic crisis for decades this country
has been dominated by a political model
a kind of ideology a political current
Perron ism which is something like a mix
of nationalism protectionism and public
spending
[Music]
si pero but in 2015 a new government
arrived that of mauricio macri with the
mission of rebuilding the country from
the top to the bottom
[Music]
yes dos Santos even Helios the same
veneer call da yo diría is cargo the
president the sooner he dinner in the
2017 legislative elections the Argentine
people renewed their trust in this
process basically they came to say well
well done Macri so the question that has
recently arisen is well this Argentina
finally ready once and for all for
takeoff well let's have a look at it
shall we
[Applause]
on October the 22nd 2017 elections for
Congress and the Senate were held in
Argentina the government coalition can
be a mas had an overwhelming triumph
with more than 10 million votes they won
15 out of the 24 electoral districts
including the top five these are the
most populated ones - Aires province
brannis aires city cordova Santa Fe and
Mendoza something like that hasn't
happened since 1985
[Music]
[Applause]
now after these elections can be a Maus
is close to having an absolute majority
which ensures the government's ability
to push their reform agenda forward for
this reason several analysts have stated
that this is the true beginning of
macri's term so after two years of power
what is mercury done what hasn't he done
Anse what are his intentions you're
gonna find the answers to all of these
questions in today's video but before we
do that let's take a look back at the
history downfall
[Music]
a century ago Argentina was one of the
richest countries in the world even
richer than countries like Canada
Australia France or even Germany and not
only that when world war ii ended on may
v8 in 1945 this country was along with
the united states one of the largest
creditors in the world and also one of
the largest gold owners on the entire
planet at that time Buenos Aires the
Argentine capital was in full swing and
could even rival New York of course
having said all of that well you might
now be wondering well what the hell
happened to Argentina well even though
things didn't look bad for this country
after the Second World War the truth is
that something it was already changing
the great international crisis of the
1930s affected this country a lot
Argentina which was a huge agricultural
exporter suffered and has had its first
major financial crisis and since that
time all those years ago nothing has
been the same
politics dear viewer began to intervene
in every economic and societal field
finally in 1946 what we could call the
definitive turn well it began the
government of general Farrell first and
then colonel juan domingo perón approved
all kinds of rules and laws more than
16-thousand in fact which puts the
economy under state control
[Music]
something which for example meant that
things like foreign trade business
creation or competition wouldn't really
be a priority instead policies such as
import substitution nationalization and
large state enterprises they became the
order of the day
[Music]
this is how a seventy year downfall
began which made Argentina become one of
the very few countries that has gone
from a developed country to a developing
country economic crisis hyperinflation
and payment suspension have become very
very common problems talked about in the
Argentinian media in recent decades and
this process culminated with Kirchner
ISM from Cristina Fernandez de Kirchner
[Music]
how to ruin a country
throughout our two terms as president
Cristina Fernandez de Kirchner set up a
model that could simply be defined as
unyk an imagined Zeenat was already
pretty terrible at business but Cristina
she took it a step further
see in CF Kay's Argentina there were
capital controls companies couldn't
repatriate their profits taxes on
companies reached in comparable
proportions in Latin America there were
lots of restrictions on imports and the
central bank was only dedicated to
making money in order to finance the
government
the model was so terribly uh neck anomic
that CFK set up a lot of taxes on
exports yes who would really think of
punishing companies that are exporting
selling to other countries
it's pretty crazy indeed who know me
Rebecca Elma determine disappear Papa
never mind
ok no podemos we will reconnect al del
resto poorest alternate with our mantra
mundo de mundo que tan Tunis costo de
Mar de que tiene que ver composer reveal
mejor SI independer tanto de la Ferrara
for supposed to get a Democrat Al
McCrory Tom Tom Tosh mucho menos diez y
para nosotros a primer mundo es él
siempre ahem
[Applause]
but that isn't all with Christina at the
helm of the Casa Rosada the Argentine
White House this country became one of
the most protectionist in all of Latin
America and also a country where setting
up companies was incredibly difficult
and of course the results they were
immediate during her second term growth
was null the public deficit soared
inflation rose to 40 percent investment
collapsed and suddenly again nothing
seemed to work
this is how in December of 2015 the
Argentinian people chose Mauricio Macri
former president of Boca jr. as the new
president of Argentina quiero ser el
Presidente que puede companion loss en
su crecimiento el presidente del
desarrollo el potentiel decade Argentina
[Music]
my visa rival Mauricio macri's first
year leading Argentina it wasn't easy
of course this was bound to happen
because of the terrible steak that he
inherited the country in for example he
reduced electricity and natural gas
subsidies for the kiss reforms never
have immediate results things didn't
look so great at the beginning in 2016
the country suffered a severe recession
with a GDP drop of 2.6 percent inflation
also approached 40 percent poverty
unemployment deficits and external debt
also increased in other words there were
ample opportunities to criticize Macri I
mean wasn't he the one you promised that
things were going to change well as we
said a minute ago reforms do not have
immediate results but in the end those
changes they do arrive
in 2017 the Argentine economy was
finally showing signs of improvements
this year's growth may exceed 3% and the
appetite for investment is already more
than evidence
yep that's right it looks like Argentina
may be coming out of that long tunnel
[Music]
Philip I'm being these results have
given Macri the great electoral victory
that we've just seen now we come to the
question of what exactly did the
president do well basically he reduced
all of the crazy regulations and
policies that have been put in place the
new government it seemed got to work
reducing these because in their eyes
there was no time to lose as soon as he
arrived he eliminated currency controls
he allowed foreign investors to
repatriate their profits he eliminated
the most incomprehensible export taxes
and reduced to subsidies and
restrictions on imports and all of this
was with one clear objective Argentina
had to recover its productive economy
also and this is really important here
Macri reached agreements with some of
the international investors that
Argentina hadn't paid in 2001 hands with
whom it still had judicial fights
Argentina reached an agreement with the
venture funds after 14 years of struggle
in total to cover all the debts with the
funds McCree offers sixty five hundred
million dollars
this agreement implies a 25% reduction
on the other hands the new government
approved a kind of fiscal amnesty which
brought to light no less than a hundred
and seventeen billion dollars the talent
in Ian's had abroad and had not declared
but before you think this is a huge
scandal do you think about what would
happen if you were afraid that your
savings could be confiscated by the
government's sometimes it's not just
about not paying taxes when states don't
have legal security it's easy for money
to simply disappear the fact is that
with all these measures macri's
government has managed to get much of
that money back to Argentina and since
then there's been an influx of money
which has triggered things like real
estate sales and car sales we are
breaking records more than seven hundred
and eighty thousand cars have been sold
to this day and most importantly trucks
this means that production is moving
construction is moving Mauricio Macri it
looks like the engine quite literally
has started again Volkswagen will invest
six hundred and fifty million u.s.
dollars to modernize plants in Argentina
[Music]
[Applause]
but one question arises and that's is
everything really so exemplary is
everything really so perfect well hold
on a man because the truth is that until
now the reforms have been very very
gradual and had a fairly limited range
something that in spite of the electoral
results and all those calls to uncork
the champagne has alerted several
experts at the moment of truth so far he
hasn't done much beyond removing
Kitchener ISM from power which isn't
little even though he did say that these
elections are the endorsement for the
reforms we don't really know what they
are what he wants to do Carlos Rodriguez
Braun Argentine economist but why so
much distrust because despite the
reforms we've seen it seems that this
government is struggling to overcome
some of the typical problems of
Argentina's previous governments for
example public spending has not
decreased it continues to rise and rise
which is caused among other things
foreign debt to soar by more than 50
billion dollars since Macri came to
power and that's not all
taxes are through the roof the central
bank continues to finance the government
with new money and according to the
latest doing business reports which
measures the ease of doing business in
the country Argentina is still way down
in one hundred and sixteenth place
now to be fair we can say the Macri has
two pretty good excuses first is that
not much time has passed
second is political position in Congress
and the Senate were very weak now but
after these last elections all of that
is finally over
a reformist agenda
[Music]
it seems that often is crushing
electoral triumph president Macri has
made it clear we are entering a stage of
permanent reform ISM Argentina doesn't
have to stop it doesn't have to fear
reforms because to reform is to grow to
evolve to progress Mauricio Macri he
certainly has a task out of him which is
somewhat complicated but well what are
his priorities well fundamentally Divya
at first it's something that is as
unpopular as it is necessary reducing
public deficit and controlling inflation
which are ultimately related then he's
going to get Argentina back to being a
competitive and attractive country in
which to invest to achieve this it has
promised to approve a tax reform that
reduces taxes on businesses and a labor
reform that facilitates hiring as well
as more free trade agreements Argentina
and Chile signed the most ambitious free
trade agreement in 20 years
then pension educational and
infrastructure reforms are next yes we
consistently say the Macri has a lot of
work to do if he wants to meet the high
expectations that have been placed on
him in any case it does seem as if a new
political and economic era has begun
Virgin Tina a good example is macri's
commitment to reducing poverty by
formalizing and extending property to
the most disadvantaged Argentina
delivers housing certificates to 1.5
million people in slums Makris
government will give them the documents
to access water and electricity legally
and by the way we will be discussing how
to fight poverty in a future video so
you know subscribe for now the question
is will this country become great once
again if they managed to deepen their
reforms and take advantage of all their
opportunities such as the lithium
industry which we've discussed
previously I've little doubt that this
will be the case and now we want to know
what you think will Argentina become a
great example for the rest of Latin
America do let us know in the comments
below as well as in this survey and I
really hope that you enjoyed this video
please hit that like button if you did
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday button on the screen
as well as below me now also do check
out our friends at the reconsider media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine and as always
thank you for watching Yossarian
de que pueda company Anglos en su
crecimiento el presidente el desarrollo
al potentiel de
[Music]